Yeah, everybody, excuse me, welcome to another Zoom call.
It's a reminder on the members site for everybody that should be your first.
Go to for.
For any announcements, so check your announcements there.
And then.
A reminder to our members, our full members that you.
You can't self-schedule anymore because we had to change that.
So if you want the member discount, which of course you do, you should need to call in and schedule.
So just call in the schedule, don't self-schedule.
Or you don't receive the member discount on the coaching calls.
Okay, let's get to your questions, make sure if you have questions.
Something you think of as we go through this, go ahead and chat in your question right there.
But let's get to the ones that were sent in.
Could fermented beef organic beef sticks be the cause of my mold or high Michael toxins?
That's a really good question.
I don't know if beef sticks or like beef jerky contains the type of mold that produces Michael toxins.
I mean, I can't get moldy.
Any food could get moldy.
But we're talking about the type of mold that produces Michael toxins.
I don't we're not really talking about the mold that grows on bread.
I don't think we're talking about if your beef sticks were moldy.
No, it is true that some beef sticks or sausages, things like that could contain grains that could have had mold in them.
And therefore could contain Michael toxins.
That's a possibility.
And I don't think any of the molds that produce Michael toxic could be run.
I should investigate that for you, but I don't think so.
I see your Michael toxic report that in the Michael toxic report, you'll see where those molds come from.
So let's say if it's as fragilis mold, where it can come from off top my head.
I think as fragilis can grow in different grains and corn and wheat and different things.
I don't think any of them are listed that they grow in meat products, but it could be run.
You can look on that Michael toxic report and see.
But to answer this, I don't think so.
Next question.
Could you explain a demon and what could be the cause and how to correct it?
So a demon is swelling and normally you'll have a demon or swelling post in injury.
So you can get a demon or swelling if you spray your ankle.
What's the purpose of that?
It serves a purpose.
What it is, is, is a hyper inflammatory response.
So it is cytokines that are in the initial inflammatory response due to an injury.
So it has a purpose to summon an immune response to the area.
Now, in a case of a injured, you know, body part like a sprained ankle, it also serves the purpose to split the area.
So that you can't move this injured joint and do further harm to the damaged ligaments and tendons.
So it serves to split it so you can't move it and it summons an immune response.
Well, why do I need an immune response to a sprayed ankle?
Well, it's just an injury.
So your body isn't, you know, knowledgeable whether you cut yourself and split your ankle open at the same time.
But you'd, you'd have a similar response.
If you took a knife and you slit your, you know, your arm by accident, you'd have an inflammatory response.
Not nearly as great as if you sprayed your wrist, but you'd have this inflammatory response.
That's the red deed. That's the increased warmth.
And that inflammatory response is an initial cytokine response that then is summons the immune system to attack any, any invaders.
So if you cut yourself, you have the ability to, you know, introduce bacteria and viruses and pathogens into your body and you need immediate immediate immune response to kill those things.
Other reasons why you get swelling is you could get swelling because you have a blockage in the drainage portal.
So think of your live battery drainage system as, as a sewer system.
So your storm sewers out on street have a purpose to take water after a rain storm and the water runs down into the street and runs the storm sewers.
And that is carried to the river or wherever the storm sewers carry the water to your city.
So same thing with your, your lymphatic system, your lymphatic system is an open ended capillary system that drains the area because you always have immune responses, you always have my injuries, you are always getting rid of endotoxins, which is waste.
And always do that, your, all your cells are undergoing a metabolic activity, giving out waste into the extra cellular spaces between the cells.
And then that waste is then carried into the lymphatic capillary system where you have check valves.
And then it is carried back to your venous system and then goes through the venous system into your hopefully through your liver and your kidneys and you get rid of this stuff.
So if you have a blockage anywhere, say if you have a mass that's pressing on a lymphatic vessel, then you could have swelling.
So if I have, you know, issues with my abdominal area and it's pressing on my iliac veins, I could have swelling in my lower extremities.
If I had surgery to remove a lymph node in my axillary area, now I'm going to have a decrease ability to get rid of normal waste in my arm.
So you get a demon that way, also what you can get with cancer is what's called a sighties, which is just another name for a demon.
That's not fully understand why a person with cancer gets a sighties that can happen in the abdominal cavity can happen in the lung cavity.
And there's different theories on how and why a sighties takes place and getting that drained is the thing to do.
So actually go in with needle and you drain that or you can get a tube but have a.
Self drain as well if that's a problem, but bottom line on how to correct it is you have to correct the reason why it's there.
Now if you had surgery, you had lymph nodes removed, now you're, you're kind of at a disadvantage because it's not as easy to correct.
Because the reason why you have the swelling is because you basically took out the storm sewer system. So now when it rains, the street, you don't fills up.
So doing different tissue massages and different things can be helpful, but you're dealing with some other things, other issues.
I do know that I have multiple blog posts on a demon, how to get rid of swelling and how to help with lymphatic detoxification.
So if you look on our website and you just search and live will probably see all our blog posts that I have some, I think videos and different things that you could do for swelling as well.
Next question, could you please explain anemia causes and how to fix it?
Well, I saw this question, I pulled the blog posts right here that I created to help explain that I understand one thing for everybody is to look at if you have a question, I want you to ask another zoom call that's what this is here for.
And then I'll point you back to a greater explanation. So like this blog post, understanding anemia with cancer, it goes into details of what you would see on your complete blood count.
And the different types of anemia, so you could have anemia of chronic disease, which is typically an iron deficiency anemia, common in cancers, you could have B12 anemia, you could have B6 anemia, you could have folate anemia.
So there's different types of anemia, the most common is the iron deficiency anemia with cancer patients because cancer can tend to gobble up iron.
And you could end on this blog post that goes into details of what you would see on a CBC and then what you would want to do with that.
So I'll refer you to that and refer you to, you know, when you have questions, if you don't want to wait, tell the zoom call, always go to our website and there's a little like a little spyglass or magnifying glass on the right hand side as you're looking at your computer on the website.
If you click on that, you'll go to a search bar and if you just typed in anemia, you would come up with a bunch of different blog posts on anemia from this one, understanding anemia with cancer to anemia, what should I do?
Another one cancer anemia and then frequency programs for anemia fatigue, what could cause it all sorts of different blog posts on that is probably 2000 blog posts, most of them have videos and they are, you know, we try to explain as many things to you as possible. So by all means ask them, but sometimes they could go into greater detail if we do have a blog post on it.
Next question with my diagnosis, is it safe for me to use collagen, I struggle with dry skin air and brittle nails.
Well, I do also also have a blog post on collagen and that though there's conflicting research with collagen and cancer.
There was research back about 20 years ago saying that collagen can be beneficial with cancer and then there's newer research that says collagen could actually drive cancer.
So when you have conflicting research with something like that that there may be, you know, that you can kind of understand that there is not a lot of bias in those in those articles.
You have to think that I typically fall on the side of I wouldn't use collagen if my cancer was really active.
So if I cancer was not active and I was in a state of relative remission, I don't think there's anything wrong with using collagen now don't confuse collagen with colostrum.
So kind of similar words there, but they're different. So collagen and colostrum are different.
Oh, it used to be very difficult to get colostrum. Now there's many sources of colostrum out there.
You don't want to use colostrum with cancer, but collagen with cancer, if you're in a state of remission or relative remission, don't think there's anything wrong with doing some collagen to help with your hair and nails.
Next question. What do you do? What do you did a new cheek swab on me? There were added supplements. Why did the show up in the first one? So the first cheek swab?
Because when we do a cheek swab test on you, I'm testing for what your body is asking for now. That's what it is. So many times it'll be the same thing. Many times we would change some dosages here and there, but it's not going to change that much.
Sometimes it can change a lot and I take you off of a whole bunch of different stuff and put you on different things. It's just just what it is.
So, you know, it's we're just reading what your body is telling us to do right now and understand also with the cheek swab, we're testing, we're locking in cancer, so we're only testing for what is going on with cancer.
We're testing for food sensitivities. It isn't testing for antibodies to different things. It's testing just for what we're dealing with with the cancer.
Do I need to be on the new supplements you suggested for the genetics for life? Well, baby, yeah. So your genetics aren't going to change.
If you're taking let's say I suggested the curcumin, let's pretend for because of your genetics.
It's because of your genetics that I suggested the curcumin. So your genetics are going to change even if your cancer is all gone and you're doing fantastic.
You still have those genes. And that curcumin that I suggested is based upon that gene is not based upon your cancer. It's based upon your genes. So yes, does it mean you have to take them the rest are like, no, you don't have to do anything. You don't want to do.
Okay, but if you want to support that genetic family that you have issues with, then that is the best way to support it. So what if I just eat a whole bunch of curcumin things and okay, well, that maybe don't have to take curcumin that day.
Okay, so it doesn't mean you have to do everything every day either, but in general, yes, those genes aren't going to change. So in general, yeah, your genes are going to be the same and you're going to want to support those pathways.
There are questions from the chat remember if you have other questions that you could think of we didn't have a ton of questions that you guys said did remember for people that are new on the member site. There's a blue box at the bottom where you could submit your zoom call questions.
So if you're a member to do that, that is the best way to get them in.
First question from the chat do you think Chinese acupuncture has any value for balancing body systems. Yes, I do. I saw Chinese acupuncture.
Some people say, well, that's a religious art. It's not. So Chinese acupuncture has nothing to do with their religion, their belief system. It's not Buddhist. It's not Hindu. It's not any of that.
It is simply helping balancing the energy up. That's where people in the past. I mean, I've done acupuncture and by practice since I graduated in 1986. So I graduated doing acupuncture. I took acupuncture classes in school. I did acupuncture a lot of people. So
it is not a religious connotation in acupuncture versus you could maybe make that argument with them with other things like different practices that you may want to stay away from.
So the acupuncture has been given a bad kind of title, especially back in the 70s when initially it was kind of brought over to the United States because it talks about energy and because you can't dissect the meridian. So it describes these these basically portals of energy across your body that are described in Chinese acupuncture as meridians.
It's separate from anatomical structures like nerves. So because medical profession couldn't dissect these meridians, they said they don't exist. Well, there's nobody in the medical profession except some ancient doctors that believe that it's very measurable now with instrumentation. You can measure its meridian flow.
You can't argue with it. Does it help? Yeah, I think it can help a lot. Does it mean you need to do it? No, I don't think you need to do it. I think your body can balance that yourself. I think your blockages in those energy can have to do a lot with your metabolic health, a lot with your chemical health, which would be your nutrition and such.
It'll be a lot with your attitude and your thought process of your prayer life. So when I do think there's value in acupuncture.
Next question. I started the right program and supplements mid December. I've reordered supplements a couple of times. How long should I continue on these supplements? How do I know if the cancer is settled down?
My next scan is in July. Just wondering if and when we should make adjustments to my supplements. So I have a video on the member site on when should you do another cheek swab. So when should you do another cheek swab is
when you are wondering whether you should make changes. So, but also you do another cheek swab if you're getting worse or you're getting better and you want to hopefully get off some things.
You do another cheek swab when you're like when you think you'd go to the doctor to get rechecked for something. You could do another cheek swab when you're getting rechecked for supplements.
Is it a good idea to do another cheek swab in any specific interval? Well, maybe in 60 days, then maybe three months, then maybe six months, but it would be different if there were changes.
If I'm doing really well, maybe you have the attitude that I'm doing really well and I'm in remission. I don't want to make any changes. Okay, then just stick with what you're doing.
But if you're doing really well in remission and I want to see if I cut down on some of these things, then maybe do another cheek swab or if I'm not feeling as well, then you would do another cheek swab.
Now, doing another cheek swab is just going to test for our protocol to answer your second question. How do I know if I cancer is settled down?
Well, then you have to do some testing. So, what are some testing things that you could do to see if my cancer has settled down?
So, we'll do a just a standard CBC and complete comprehensive metabolic profile. What we call our complete wellness panel would be a good idea because there's going to be clues and hints in that if the person's getting better or worse.
It's fairly inexpensive to 150 bucksish to get a to keep an eye on that. If I like the question before, if I have an EVF by an EVF is getting worse, that can be a clue that my cancer is not getting better.
Or if I have different markers in my cup or has a metabolic pedal that are getting worse at my alkaline phosphatase is going up. If I asked you and ALT, other liver markers are going up, that can give us clues to different things.
Remember every test is giving you clues to help with your differential diagnosis as you go through this process and you weigh it out with your subjective data as well.
So, getting a standard blood test CBC and comprehensive metabolic profile.
Number three would be getting two markers done. If you have a cancer that typically will show two markers, that could be a beneficial thing to do.
So, obvious one would be prostate with PSA, breast cancer with CA 153, CA 1999, 2729, a CEA.
So, and then, and a gradic cancer, CA 1999, so you could do a tumor marker panel, a female or male tumor marker panel.
I haven't done any of those at all. Well, it might be good to just get that run. So we have a baseline of where you're at because that could give us clues.
Again, nothing's perfect, but it can give us clues to whether we're getting better or getting worse or staying stable.
And then you get into more detailed or invasive testing like an MRI or CT skin or a PET skin.
So, short of that, doing X-rays, short of that, maybe doing ultrasound, depending on what type of cancer you have.
So, those are the ways that you would measure our progress. I do a video of that as well on the member site.
I don't know if I'm getting better, I think today, but the video is so that would be a good thing to watch. And another video on what blood tests a cancer patient should do.
That would be another good video to watch.
All those things, I think, would be beneficial.
Next question. From what I read on my Michael Toxins report, depending on the type, where are there are so many foods you can get them from.
It's difficult to avoid them all. What supplements are used to detox Michael Toxins in particular.
So, Michael Toxins are Toxins. They're inter-substances like heavy metals or poisons or chemicals.
So, any of the keylators were so depending on what I may recommend for you. There's there's keylators that are specifically named for Michael Toxins like Michael pull from research nutritionals.
But, you know, that's not any better of a Michael Toxin detoxifier than some of the other binders and keylators out there. It just has the name Michael in it. So, that's how they're marketed.
So, any keylator or binder can help pull that out of your body. Yes, there are a lot of foods that you could get Michael Toxins from.
But, you look at the type of Michael Toxins you have and if they, if it is the type of Michael Toxins that you can get from food.
You have to kind of weigh out what are what are the most common ways of getting them. It's just like anything else that you get poisons from my environment.
What are the most common ways that I get those poisons. Well, you know, they're, you know, from, you know, our foods that we eat and from the things that we breathe in and things that we spray on our lawn and think chemicals that we use at our house.
So, we make changes that we can make that we can live with. We can't be obsessive compulsive about it and we would not be able to live in this world.
So, you have to have a balance of what you can do and what you're willing to do.
Because I've said this to just what everybody would I've gone over your reports. I've had people that have just like been flammergasted at there at their toxicity report, you know, with multiple toxicities and cannot believe that this is true because they meet organic their entire life and they've just, you know, have lived such a clean existence.
Well, remember, your level of toxicity at any given time is equal to your the degree of toxic exposure, whether you're breathing them in, which is ubiquitous everywhere, whether you're eating them, which is cross contaminated, even in your organic food, whether you're exposed to on your skin, whether you're, you know, however they're getting in your system, your level of
toxicity is equal to your level of exposure minus your ability to detoxify. So, many times people have issues with detoxification pathways can be genetic issues with detoxification pathways so that they're just slow detoxers.
If that's the case, your level of exposure may not even be that high because you're doing so many things well, but you just don't get rid of what you what you take in and you're not you're so your level of toxicity is hot, relatively high.
But it's not just genetic issues, you know, if you damage your liver over the years, you, you know, record alcohol, you, you know, taken medications, you underwent surgeries with had to be on drugs, probably the number one damage to our liver is is medications.
I don't take any medications never prescription medications, but I'm on Tylenol every day. Okay, well, I mean 15,000 people a year in the United States die of Tylenol poisoning every single year.
I would hear about those kind of things we are exposed to so many poisons so many things that damage our liver permanently decrease our ability to detoxify.
And then then we these things build up at our system and can cause all sorts of issues so that's just the simple facts of like so you have to make that decision where you draw that line and know that, you know, toxins are probably going to eventually kill us all so you we all have to make that decision where we're going to draw that line.
Next question do I need to leave 30 to 45 minutes on either side of homeopathic radiation drops avoiding mint and caffeine et cetera.
I wouldn't say 30 to 45 minutes at say 15 to 30 minutes. Yes, that's why I typically recommend people to take them, you know, at night before you go to bed or right away in the morning.
But you're going to have to time your teeth brushing because most people have mint in their toothpaste now she would binders, you know, so a lot of people are taking binder binding agents and I tell them to take that 30 minutes away from other food.
Now, the binders you could take mint is not going to bother a binder, okay, so if you're taking a biotoxin binder HM ET binder or whatever you're that's mint is not going to affect that mint.
Spiramid peppermint affects holioplastics not binder so you don't have to worry about your teeth brushing thing of a binder but with homeopathic drops, yes, you don't have to worry about those things don't worry about them, just don't do it.
If you heard of this product or detoxified radiation diacin vitamin A vitamin D vitamin C.
Vitamin E B complex and B one.
No, I haven't a diacin will help open up your vessels that's what the whole purpose of taking extra diacin would do it could it could dilate your vessels.
Vitamin A is needed for your heart and so and so many things D that's fairly small amount of D.
Vitamin C at two grams that means you'd probably be absorbing from on half of that that would be an antioxidant if you have cancer.
I would suggest taking that level of vitamin C the B complex is something I probably wouldn't recommend to most people with cancer because it probably has methyl groups so but otherwise I don't know how that is helping with radiation detoxification over those things.
Next question by carapactor today told me about something he called bone panel.
Blood work that's supposed to tell you what is affecting bone tissue and differentiates between damage likely from cancer or rickets etc.
Have you ever heard of this he suggested as a baseline to keep closer tab I didn't ask him what the labs are included yet.
Okay, so just understand if you have bone loss so if you do a test for those tests for osteoporosis and osteopaedia that shows your percentage of bone loss.
That is I never have ever recommended those tests I just I don't I don't want to see a whole lot of value in those I don't think that's what he's talking about here.
What if you have a bone loss let's say it's you have bone loss CD X ray or bone loss CD and a cat scan or a cat scan that scan would show that about activity but bone loss CD or CT scan or X ray you have quite a bit of bone loss.
You would know if you had rickets or something like that when you're doing a differential diagnosis of why a person has bone loss.
You're looking at that person's history you're looking at other things if I had bone loss due to osteoporosis or osteopaedia.
I would not show an elevated alkaline phosphatase nor show an elevated calcium you're only going to get an elevated alkaline phosphatase an elevated calcium if you have rapid destruction of bone so osteopaedia and osteoporosis is not a rapid destruction of bone.
So I don't know the value of any kind of bone panel blood work.
I don't know exactly what this person is talking about so I don't know of any value of that so when you're when you're contemplated you know why I might have changes in my blood work.
You go through a differential diagnosis of trying to figure that out let's say if I have.
I don't have no cancer and I have elevated or rising alkaline phosphatase levels and rising calcium levels that's a clue in the clue that that should give you is that there can be destruction so you can have elevated alkaline phosphatase and that's going to be found in your liver panel.
Which would be a simple.
Metabolic panel or a comprehensive metabolic panel so you'd have an elevated alkaline phosphatase and elevated a rising high level of calcium that's going to be suggestive of bony destruction.
Now you can't have an elevated alkaline phosphatase due to destruction of other tissues too.
Most commonly would be liver but then you'd also most likely have elevated ST and ALT so those are the kind of the things that you look at when you're looking at your lab work.
ALT is elevated my ST is elevated my alkaline phosphatase is elevated then I go huh do I do I possible with it with a history of cancer do I possibly have a test assistant to my liver or do I possibly have toxicity to my liver what am I.
I'm thinking that could cause toxicity to deliver and died denied out of 100 times it's going to be a medication so even over the counter medication like Tylenol or Edville or Fennband is all can cause those things so when you if that's why I ask if you're on Fennband is all or I've erected or you're taking Tylenol or you're doing that those things then.
Then make sure you're getting a liver panel to be able to look at those numbers to know that you're not getting toxicity to deliver.
So that's kind of how you go through that thing then if you think okay come through a differential diagnosis there's something I don't not on any type of medications that do have a history of cancer and my liver numbers are rising and my calcium numbers are rising then it might be time to.
Get a PET scan done to see where there's metabolic activity that the PET scan shows positive to the liver or shows positive to the bone then then you could say well that's probably why these numbers work up so that's how you kind of put the whole picture together well you're going through this process called differential diagnosis so all tests give you clues and.
You just need to know how to read those clues now if everything I said to you is common knowledge that's great but if everything I said just said to you is like what did you say I have videos I don't know this stuff so okay well what what is this alcohol and phosphatase mean well that's a that's a figure on your on your.
Copperheads and metabolic pedal well I have blog posts on that's called elevated alcohol phosphatase what can this mean so I go through that and there's a video multiple videos on that blog post because I've spoken about this multiple times so then you can see what a normal range is see what.
You know to go through this yourself too so now I want you guys to use the zoom calls for these questions so these are brilliant questions and and but I also what the whole purpose of these
purpose of these own causes for you guys to get smarter and smarter and smarter so you can educate your family and help take care of your family and and help yourself and help your family and your loved ones that's the whole purpose of these and I you know we might at least one of my purposes in life is to you know try to educate people and teach people when I learn something so I just try to make videos and put that out there.
So utilize our our blogs for these or all of that too because you learn a lot and I'll let you to be very wise.
Did you get my cheek swab in the mail yes I wrote you two requests for this one with a sample of light so please read both I had made more thoughts than in the mail okay I did not open it up yet we just got it today.
Any other questions Ben Ben does all and I don't get along is there something else I could be doing when I'm off so if
you don't detoxify a drug very well it's going to affect your liver right so it can affect your kidneys it can affect your liver so
and I've said that with it's with any drug so different drugs detoxify in different different different than of all of pathways and genetic pathways in your liver you have your NAT pathways one and two that are common drug detoxifies your five detoxifiers you have your site of quote for 50 pathways you have your pun one pathways in others so if you have defects in those pathways you some
you just don't detoxify certain drugs very well and then they can become toxic to your liver and how do you know that like I said you'll see an elevation in in your your liver markers your
ST your ALT your own lymphosphatase so then you have to pause that for a while now some people they just have to pause it for good they just can't take that drug so you know you can't
well I got a risk in any how I'm just going to go for it because I got to get rid of this cancer because there's lots of things that will get rid of your cancer
not just Ben Ben does all or I have her back to just because that's the hip thing right now okay how many of you went with me long enough that they hey the hip thing a few years ago
was was THC and Rick Simpson oil and half of our zoom calls were questions about that because that was the hip thing then just because there's a lot of scuttle but in the news about something
doesn't mean it's the only thing out there good to say we saw remarkable changes in people's cancer that were given weeks to live
and never used Ben Ben does all you know never used I've erected none of those things were available none of it was even known about we didn't use Rick Simpson oil
so know that those don't don't get in your mind that I if I don't take that that's I'm not going to you know it's not going to work
that only about 10% of you that are listening to this are that stuff so it doesn't it just doesn't test well for a lot of people
and it doesn't work well with your liver with a lot of people so don't worry about that I wouldn't do anything else right now while you're on
next question heard of eucalyptus T enemas to kill parasite eggs
nope I haven't heard of eucalyptus T enemas to kill parasite eggs I think that remember
so if you're going to do an enema with anything whether you're going to do coffee enemas or you're going to do
do you know T enemas of any kind or you're going to put essential oils in your enemas it's only going into your lower rectal area
it's not going up into your colon and you know crossing through your Iliosecle valve into your small intestines
if it did you would be one sick puppy so it's not doing that so you're in your to do something
rectally to kill parasites I don't know about that I don't know how far enough to get
do you have any articles about the relationship between hypothyroid liver function and hormones
when you add in cortisol and anemia it seems very hard to figure out what is causing which thing
but they can all affect cancer yeah I don't know if there's any articles or research if that's what you're asking about
the connection with all those things with cancer for sure if you go on the chronic disease in autoimmune course
module 6 is all about thyroid that may be helpful to you as far as liver function and hormones
there's probably lots of data out there I don't know the direct correlation with you know with as far as like
estrogen and progesterone testosterone with liver function as far as cortisol levels and anemia
I think the only correlation with that is symptoms so if you have really low cortisol really low function
adrenal it can give you the same symptoms as anemia so having to differentiate what my symptoms are coming from is the issue there
and then adding in the whole picture of cancer no again one of the things I've always said is that you look at subjective data
when you're looking at whether a cancer is getting worse or better and one of the most common things that you're going to see
subjectively with cancer besides possibly pain but many times many cancers don't produce pain
that would be more in like colorectal cancer or pancreatic cancer maybe prostate cancer
but more so would be fatigue so a person you know if your fatigue is long lasting fatigue that can be a clue that your cancer could be worsening
well why would a person with cancer get fatigue you know it's not just magically you get tired because your cancer is growing
no you're when if the cancer is growing it can cause anemia and therefore give you fatigue
so unless your cancer is on your adrenal glands or affecting your adrenal glands directly it's not going to cause cancer
it's typically not going to cause low adrenals so the cancer is typically not going to affect cortisol levels directly
but so getting how would you measure that then objectively you you look at a CBC and you can see if you have anemia or not
now if you have a CBC and you have a history of anemia that's a historical thing
and and then your subjective findings are getting worse if you're anemia and you can look at past blood work and your anemia hasn't worsened at all
then you have to look at other causes is it other hormonal is it adrenal is it pituitary is it thyroid
so yeah you do it to look at other causes now I realize that very few people are have cancer as an eyelid in itself
you have you know multiple cold morbidities that you do want to deal with if you can so you are finding the battle at multiple fronts
when you're dealing with any disease so it does become challenging to say the least
and you just have to kind of fight your way through those muddy waters to get to that level of feeling as best as you possibly can
okay I think with that we will bid a do thanks everybody for being on today and remember to use our member site
and remember to go to our website and search the blogs too so you don't have to wait till this call each time so
have a blessed day I'll be praying for all of you and we cherish your prayers for us bye bye